[Musique]
c'était toujours j'aimerais savoir plus
dans la vie avant de servir le vin sans
wafeer marcèle lamarche qui directeur du
chaînon qui est ma cliente comme une
monnaie doute n'était prochaine où j'ai
commencé à chercher bon naturellement cd
dont donc on a demandé à des des
contacts des amis dans l'industrie bhl
[Musique]
ce qu'on établit pour la première année
c'est de le faire ce soit à l'intérieur
d'hôtels cinq étoiles
la première fois je suis venu je me
disais peut-être qu'on voit à moins
habiles et beaucoup avec leurs le côté
dramatique difficile de ces gens là au
moment où il rentre dans le salon et
s'assoit sur la chaise unis midi pour
l'état la main c'est comme des vrais
clients de coloration contenu impie
maquillage etc
bah oui c'est beau une femme sans doute
le regard de tous les droits différents
on l'avait repos que minutes inhérents
on la voit pas comme une victime n avoir
pas comme une proie
e
je me rappelle que d'une journée on a
fait une dame on la coiffer maquiller et
c est venu me voir par des côtés dit ça
fait longtemps que j'ai pas vu mon fils
a dit là c'est la mer jaune et je
m'habille sortante géraldine droit les
larmes aux yeux
d'après ce que j'ai compris jusqu'à voir
les bras son fils il va avoir un autre
sujet que la souffrance et d'itinérance
[Musique]
des femmes qui ont des problèmes de
santé mentale donc on a besoin des
points un peu plus d'attention de faire
attention au toucher c'est très fragile
pour des femmes qui ont souvent n'ont
pas été touchés depuis longtemps n'ont
pas été ils n'ont pas eu de la tension
leur donner autant d'importance j'ai un
dentiste qui maudit 1 et clients il m'a
dit il vient de me donner une idée je
pense que dans ma ville je vais prendre
une deux personnes par année à ma charge
pour donner un coup de main comme ça au
japon
[Musique]
à
ici tout le monde faisait ça dans son
petit patelin je pense qu'on aurait
massa serait une différence pour énorme
pour les gens
[Musique]
tous les coiffeurs qui sont venus ici
jusqu'à date nous aider m'ont rappelé
mon équipe on dit merci de m'avoir donné
cette chance là dit moi quand je peux
revenir
ce qui me motive moi de le faire c'est
que ça me fait plaisir ça donne un sens
à mon métier mais je crois que de se
faire coiffer de se faire métamorphosé
peut donner des ailes à ses fans l'homme
[Musique]
et